[Music]
could a post-slap Will Smith win another
Oscar is emancipation based on a true
story here's all you need to know before
seeing Smith's next big film
in just a few months Will Smith's
historical drama emancipation will be
hitting theaters and dropping on Apple
TV plus and there are already people
with extremely high hopes for this
emotionally charged action epic based on
a true story emancipation is intended to
shine a light on the United States most
turbulent time in history the American
Civil War and the height of slavery in
the South Early reactions to the film
have so far been very strong with most
people who've seen it offering up
immense praise for the subject matter
and themes on social media according to
deadline a private screening of
emancipation was held in early October
by Apple original films and the NAACP
members of the Congressional Black
Caucus historically black college and
universities the Divine 9 National
Council of negro women the National
Coalition on black civic participation
and other prominent groups were invited
on October 24th Smith also held a
private screening of emancipation for
some of his celebrity friends including
Rihanna Dave Chappelle and ASAP Rocky
Smith later took to his Instagram page
to commemorate the event saying epic
night thanks for coming to see
emancipation hope you all enjoyed
but what everyone wants to know is when
the public can actually see the
historical film according to Apple
emancipation will get a limited release
in theaters on December 2nd before
hitting Apple TV Plus on December 9th
which is right in time for award season
film experts and critics expect Will
Smith despite his 2022 Oscar controversy
to still be in the running for another
gold statue next year associate
professor of film studies at the
University of Sydney Bruce Isaacs
tweeted there is huge Oscar buzz around
emancipation for those who somehow
missed what happened at the Academy
Awards Smith basically turned his entire
life and career upside down he did so
with a swift slap to the face of
comedian Chris Rock following a joke
that rock made about Smith's wife Jada
Pinkett Smith Rock who was on stage
presenting an award had poked fun at
Jada for having a shaved head which is
reportedly due to alopecia Smith would
later apologize for his actions in an
Instagram statement saying his behavior
was quote unacceptable and inexcusable
he also released a recorded response on
YouTube in July 2022 that featured
multiple apologies to both Rock and his
family no this is probably irreparable
with emancipation not coming out until
December many experts feel like there's
been enough time and apologies made by
Smith for him to snag another best actor
awarded next year's Oscars especially
given the movie's subject matter
emancipation is a film that centers
around an enslaved man from the 1860s
who escapes from a plantation and
travels across the swamps of Louisiana
to reunite with his family it's
ultimately based on the true story of
whipped Peter who became famous during
that time period for a picture that was
taken of a severely scarred and whipped
back the image was published in the
independent and Harper's Weekly and
helped open the nation's eyes to the
horrors of slavery especially in the
south
screenwriter Bill collage reportedly
used Civil War era documents and Peter's
very own Diaries to help pin the script
back in September 2021 Will Smith spoke
to GQ Magazine about what Drew him to
the Emancipation story despite being
hesitant to do movies about slavery in
the past this includes Django Unchained
which he famously turned down Smith said
this was one that was about love and the
power of black love and that was
something that I could rock with we were
going to make a story about how black
love makes us invincible
the official Apple Studios description
of emancipation describes Smith's Peter
as a slave who manages to escape from a
Louisiana Plantation after being almost
whipped to death it further reads he had
to outwit cold-blooded hunters and the
unforgiving swamps of Louisiana on a
torturous Journey North
in addition to Will Smith emancipation
is set to feature a number of familiar
faces hell or high water and 310 to Yuma
star Ben Foster is slated to play a
slave Hunter named fascal legendary
character actor Stephen OGG will be
portraying a man named Sergeant Howard
other cast members include Charmaine
bingwa Gilbert awore Mustafa Shakir
Grant Harvey Timothy Hutton Michael
owaye and several others
speaking to the guardian in April 2022
Foster described how the story that
inspired emancipation had really moved
and resonated with him especially since
he had just finished making Barry
Levinson's the Survivor about real-life
Auschwitz Survivor and boxer Harry haft
Foster said emancipations about escaping
the camps that America created with the
African-American slave trade the Stark
similarities that I learned particularly
after visiting Auschwitz are staggering
we are students and as students it's not
uncommon to feel a burden of new
information and it takes a moment to
digest
legendary Training Day director Antoine
Fuqua is ultimately the one responsible
for bringing emancipation to life with
him serving as both director and
executive producer on the film he spoke
to deadline in depth over the summer
about what inspired him to get in the
director's chair and how the story of
whipped Peter is something that moved
him as both a filmmaker and a person
Fuqua said
it was the first viral image of the
brutality of slavery that the world saw
it's almost two years now from when I
first read the script it hit my heart
and my soul in so many ways that are
impossible to convey he explained how
whipped Peter's story hit close to home
because of its family themes Peter after
all wouldn't give up until he returned
to his family
I will look in Triumph
at my enemies
[Music]